إطلاق صواريخ من الصين باتجاه
مضيق تايوان تقترب الطائرات المقاتلة الصينية
من الجزيرة. تصعد بكين من
تخويفها لتايوان بسبب
زيارة رئيسة مجلس النواب الأمريكية نانسي بيلوسي
للصين تقول إنها تشن حصارًا
حول الجزيرة يوم الخميس
ذكرت وسائل الإعلام الصينية الحكومية أن صواريخ حلقت فوق
تايوان لأول مرة.  قبل وقت من الوقوع
في المياه القريبة ، أعلنت بكين بعد ذلك
تعليق
تعاونها مع الولايات المتحدة بشأن القضايا الرئيسية بما في ذلك
المحادثات بين قادة الدفاع
والتنسيق بشأن الهجرة
الدولية والمخدرات غير المشروعة
والمحادثات المناخية بينما
تضغط الصين على الصواريخ في جميع أنحاء
تايوان التي قرروها.
أنهم سوف يقطعون الاتصالات
مع الولايات المتحدة ، الأمر الذي يضيف فقط إلى
احتمال سوء الفهم من
قبل أي من الجانبين
يلقي كل من الولايات المتحدة والصين باللوم على كل من الصين الأخرى التي
اختارت المبالغة في رد الفعل
واستخدام زيارة المتحدث بيلوسي كذريعة
لزيادة النشاط العسكري الاستفزازي.
لا يوجد أي مبرر
لهذه الحالة
المتطرفة  رد
عسكري متفاوت ومتصاعد ،
قفز الغرب
بعض أتباعه إلى اتهام الصين بالمبالغة في رد الفعل إذا
كانوا قلقين حقًا بشأن
السلام والاستقرار الإقليميين ، فلماذا لم يرسلوا في
وقت سابق لمنع بيلوسي من
القيام بزيارة استفزازية لتايوان
الصين حلقت في رحلة غير مسبوقة  قال عدد من
الطائرات المقاتلة عبر الخط الوسطي
للطيارين في جيش التحرير الشعبي لمضيق تايوان
إنهم متحمسون للاقتراب جدًا من
الجزيرة
عندما أغفلت الساحل
لجزيرة تايوان ، أصبح
تصميمي على حماية
السلامة الإقليمية للوطن الأم
أكثر حزماً كل هذا  الغضب بعد
زيارة استمرت يومين ، وجود بيلوسي
في تايوان صفعة في وجه بكين
التي تصر على أن الجزيرة ذات الحكم الذاتي
هي مقاطعة صينية متمردة بيلوسي
خارج تايوان لكنها تركت أزمة
وراءها يخشى الكثيرون في المنطقة
من انتقام بكين.  بدأت للتو